et notre envie de politique ce matin
c'est Philippe juin bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous députés
les républicains des Hauts-de-Seine chef
du service des urgences de l'hôpital
Georges Pompidou à Paris merci d'être
avec nous on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
et l'inquiétude sur le front de
l'épidémie triple épidémie mais
notamment les chiffres de l'épidémie de
covid qui remonte philippe Juvin est-ce
qu'il faut rendre le masque obligatoire
dès maintenant
d'abord il faut le porter ça c'est une
certitude je ne le disais pas il y a
quelques semaines mais l'augmentation
des cas l'encombrement de l'hôpital le
problème c'est que l'épidémie de covid
arrive au même moment que l'épidémie de
grippe qui arrive au même moment
face à un système de santé extrêmement
fatigué et usé et donc dans tous nos
services d'urgence désormais nous avons
des gens qui dorment sur les brancards
avec des risques d'accident comme on l'a
vu il y a quelques jours avec des
patients qu'on a retrouvé mort sur des
brancards c'est ça en pratique des
patients que nous n'arrivons pas opérer
parce que nous n'avons pas de lit pour
les garder à l'hôpital avant et après
l'intervention etc etc donc aujourd'hui
il y a des gens qui ne sont pas soignés
aux urgences
qui en France ont probablement des
retards dans leur diagnostic de cancer
dans leur mise en route d'une
chimiothérapie donc on ne parle pas de
petites choses dans des traitements
chirurgicaux vous savez quand vous avez
une fracture du col du fémur qui est une
fracture extrêmement banale à partir
d'un certain âge c'est la femme en
particulier on sait que vous ne paierez
pas cette fracture dans les 48 heures
mais vous mettez plus de temps à
l'opérer et bien vous avez une
surmortalité et une sur morbidité vous
faites plus de complications très
clairement aujourd'hui il est assez
probable que un certain nombre de
patients sont loin d'être opérés dans
les 48 heures donc oui on a un système
qui est qui est l'épidémie de covid ne
tombe pas au meilleur moment donc pour
le masque oui il faudrait le mettre bien
entendu il faut le rendre obligatoire
vous trouvez que le gouvernement tarde
trop à rendre la question de faut-il le
rendre obligatoire je suis partagé
idéalement oui mais la question que je
me pose c'est est-ce que quand vous
rendez obligatoire quelque chose et que
vous n'êtes pas capable de le faire
respecter vous êtes efficace je ne sais
pas aujourd'hui le gouvernance serait
pas capable de faire respecter cette
mesure à votre avis moi je ne sais pas
regarder le matin dans le RER
aujourd'hui c'est clair vous avez raison
quand on tous ceux qui prennent les
transports en commun le savent personne
ne porte le masque mais très peu je
trouve que depuis quelques jours ça
augmente on est loin d'être
la priorité c'est très insuffisant la
question que je veux poser ça veut dire
aussi que l'appel à responsabilité qui
consiste à dire portez-le c'est
important ça ça marche pas sauf que ce
qu'il faut l'imposer non mais sauf que
pardon l'appel à la responsabilité moi
je trouve que le gouvernement est très
très discret sur les recommandations et
je vous parle pas des recommandations
je pense que le gouvernement a peur
c'est la pétoche d'être un populaire
parce qu'il a l'impression que les gens
sont fatigués par le virus ce qui est
vrai et les messages sont les publicités
vous avez vu les les clips vidéos du
gouvernement sur j'appelle à la
vaccination et honnêtement c'est
incompréhensible il y a il se passe de
longues secondes avant qu'on comprenne
qu'on nous parle de la vaccination le
truc il est simple à dire il sait dire
écoutez vaccinez-vous contre la grippe
et vaccinez-vous contre le covid point
final il faut pourquoi d'abord pour pas
attraper le covid pour ne pas faire de
forme grave ça tout le monde commence à
le connaître mais aussi et ça on
commence à le découvrir
le covid crée des séquelles à terme donc
des gens qui plusieurs mois après son
malade et pas n'importe quelle maladie
je vous donne deux exemples ça s'appelle
le covid long quand vous avez un covid
versus vous n'avez pas de covid vous
avez deux fois plus de chance de
développer un diabète dans les mois qui
suivent un diabète vous n'aviez pas de
diabète vous avez une covid vous avez un
diabète deux fois plus de chance et
deuxièmement sur le cerveau on sait qu'à
certains nombre de gens qui ont eu le
covid garde des séquelles qui sont des
séquelles cognitives difficultés de se
concentrer brouillard intellectuelle et
quand on met ça en parallèle avec des
IRM du cerveau et des examens très
précis du cerveau s'il y a deux papiers
dans Nature qui est un très grand
journal scientifique qui l'ont montré il
y a quelques jours et bien le cerveau de
celui qui a fait un covid grave c'est le
c'est un cerveau de vieillard mais en
fait vous avez un vieillissement
beaucoup plus rapide de votre cerveau
quand vous avez fait un covid grave à
tout ça la conséquence c'est mettez un
masque et vaccinez-vous quand vous dites
c'est clair le problème c'est quand on
regarde les chiffres comment est-ce que
vous expliquez que 21% seulement des
plus de 80 ans alors que c'est des
populations très exposées ne soient pas
ne pas fait de rappel covid que 10% des
plus de 60 ans pardon seulement et fait
le rappelle covid c'est l'inverse
pendant un mois
mais c'est très peu très très bien la
grippe c'est pareil un gros retard parce
que je suis allé voir avant c'est
tellement compliqué les indications de
la vaccination avant l'émission je suis
allé les revoir sur le site mais
honnêtement il m'a fallu 5 minutes pour
comprendre ce qu'on met que c'est un
défaut de communication mais c'est
incompréhensible lisez les
recommandations de vaccination cette
incompréhensible en fait c'est
incroyable c'est compliqué à comprendre
alors quand on est peut-être enfin en
plus quand on n'a pas l'habitude moi je
suis médecin en théorie je devrais
peut-être plus comprendre plus
facilement ces trucs là que d'autres qui
sont pas formés mais je trouve que c'est
incompréhensible bien un défaut
d'information qui est lié encore une
fois je le répète à cette impression que
oui on va pas embêter les Français avec
le covid ils sont fatigués ça va nous
rendre à populaire moi je crois que non
courage politique
on veut toujours trouver un coupable en
faisant c'est lui de mon travail je
viens d'arriver
non c'est le système entier fait que on
n'ose pas dire très clairement les
choses parce qu'on a peur de déplaire
mais moi je vais vous dire je m'en fiche
je déplaire vous invitez je trouve que
je suis député mais aussi médecin donc
je vous dis des choses c'est simple
quand on a quand on est vacciné on fait
moins souvent des formes graves on fait
moins souvent des séquelles c'est
séquelles mais on fait moins aussi des
formes légères légères
en Grande-Bretagne on compte ce qu'on
appelle les covidons on les on les
compte en France on les compte pas très
cool tout se passe bien enfin c'est la
France quoi donc en Grande-Bretagne il
est compté donc ils savent combien il y
en a ils estiment tenez-vous bien que
600000 britanniques 600 000 britanniques
un an après le covid ont encore des
séquelles et en particulier des
séquelles cognitives des difficultés à
se concentrer 600 000 personnes c'est un
problème médical mais c'est aussi un
problème sociaux économique 600 000
personnes qui sont pas en état de
travailler bah ça écoutez je suis désolé
mais il faut le dire même si ça déplaît
même si les gens disent ils nous
embêtent avec son covid moi je vous dis
les choses j'ai fini pour ça sur ce que
vous nous avez dit au début de cette
interview sur ce que vous constatez
comme situation à l'hôpital est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous en êtes à faire un
tri des patients
pardon mais à l'hôpital on fait toujours
le tri enfin il y a toujours un tri
quand vous avez quand vous êtes de garde
en réanimation le soir et que vous avez
un lit de libre et que le SAMU vous
appelle vous propose deux patients vous
choisissez entre les deux donc on
appelle ça le tri alors c'est pas très
beau mais ça revient ça donc on fait
toujours du tri au sens qu'on fait
toujours du choix maintenant il est très
clair qu'à partir du moment où on a
moins de litres disponible parce qu'on a
moins de personnes pourquoi il y a pas
de lit peut-être il y a pas de personnel
pourquoi il y a pas de personnel non pas
parce qu'on a pas de poste ouvert il y a
plein de postes ouverts c'est que les
postes sont vacants parce que les gens
ne les prennent pas sujet financier un
sujet de motivation etc etc et bien
c'est vrai quand vous avez moins de lits
disponibles vous êtes obligés de choisir
qui vous allez opérer en priorité qui
vous allez passer au scanner le premier
quand vous avez 15 personnes qui
attendent un scanner et ben vous dites
je vais faire d'abord celui-ci celui-là
forcément forcément pourquoi est-ce que
pour soulager puisque vous le dites hein
les postes ne sont pas pourvu est-ce que
pour soulager l'hôpital il faut
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
non non il faut pas il faut pas d'abord
parce que ça résout pas le problème de
l'hôpital la question c'est combien il y
a de soignants non vaccinés question et
la réponse bah voilà sur les sur les
d'abord on sait pas trop parce que
personne ne parle de 10000 à peu près
sur les infirmières au moins j'ai un
chiffre sur les infirmières c'est moins
de 10 en moyenne moins de 10 par
département moins de 10 par département
c'est donc en fait c'est une minorité
en nombre en nombre maintenant je vais
vous dire une chose très simple moi je
considère que quelqu'un qui ne veut pas
se faire vacciner il a le droit de pas
se faire vacciner
pour des raisons qui a étudié parfois
des mauvaises mais enfin il fait ce
qu'il veut il faut pas qu'il soit au
contact c'est pas possible parce que
quand vous êtes vacciné contrairement à
ce que un certain nombre de gens déclare
dans la presse avec une sorte de
bouillie intellectuelle qui est
généralisée quand vous êtes vacciné vous
avez moins souvent la maladie que quand
vous êtes pas vacciné et quand vous
n'avez pas la maladie par définition
vous pouvez vous ne pouvez pas la
transmettre à votre passion donc c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'un soignant doit
être vacciné moi je préfère que ma
grand-mère de 93 ans fragile soit prise
en charge par une aide-soignante un
médecin ou une infirmière vacciné
c'est-à-dire protéger quand même
vous le regrettez moi je suis député
républicains de la majorité en tout cas
républicain
le le le le réintégration des des des
des des des soignants vaccinés parce que
je pense encore une fois que moi je veux
protéger les patients voilà bon voilà et
puis je crois la science c'est idiot
hein mais je crois ce qui est marqué
dans les livres de science enfin vous
nous dites on a pas de chiffre du
covidon est-ce que vous arrivez à
chiffrer la mortalité on a les chiffres
de la mentalité ni au covid est-ce que
vous arrivez à chiffrer la mortalité lié
au séquelles du covid lié aux
conséquences des déprogrammations
il y a les c'est quand je peux avoir les
séquelles est-ce qu'il y a une mortalité
il y a c'est séquelles je ne sais pas je
ne pense pas en tout cas elle est pas
écrite maintenant est-ce que le fait que
la désorganisation du système parce que
c'est ça que vous dites effectivement le
système est désorganisé par le covid et
la grippe et et l'affaiblissement du
système est-ce qu'on a une surmortalité
probablement je pense qu'on pense que
personne ne l'a mesuré puisse être très
difficile à mesurer ça ça ne peut se
mesurer si vous voulez que un an plus
tard quand vous comparez la mortalité
globale l'année moins 1 et l'année en
question mais il est sûr ce qu'on sait
dans la littérature là pour le coup il y
a des papiers qui montrent quand vous
avez une surcharge aux urgences
vous avez par définition une
augmentation des complications et des
morts ça c'est une donnée internationale
vous parlez de surcharge aux urgences on
a parlé et du covid et de la grippe il y
a aussi la broncholite il y a la
bronchiolite pardon il y a la semaine
dernière vous êtes 10000 soignants qui
ont signé une tribune en alertant en
disant que la situation aux urgences
pdatriques étaient catastrophiques
est-ce que vous confirmez qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire par rapport à cette
situation
social qui touche les nourrissons mais
qui touche aussi les les plus âgés
attention on oublie un peu cette affaire
bah qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
qu'est-ce qui nous manque en France il
nous manque une politique de prévention
très clairement et il nous manque des
lits ouverts pour pouvoir hospitaliser
les gens quand vous allez aujourd'hui
vous êtes malade je ne suis pas certain
de vous trouver un lit pour vous
hospitaliser on en est là alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour ouvrir
des lits mais il faut du personnel
pour avoir du personnel qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire il y a deux choses il faut en
former nous ne formons pas suffisamment
de personnel alors chaque fois on me dit
ah bah oui mais former une infirmière ça
va mettre trois ans d'accord mais enfin
on aurait commencé il y a trois ans on
commencerait à les avoir moi j'étais
dans le bureau de Jean Castex en fin
2020 il m'avait invité ou convoqué en me
disant monsieur Juvin vous dites partout
que il faut ouvrir des lits avec du
personnel mais on n'a pas le personnel
alors je dis monsieur le Premier
ministre ouvrez des générations
nouvelles des promotions nouvelles
d'écoles d'infirmières multiplier les
places dans les écoles d'infirmières et
puis ou d'aide-soignante et on va les
former il me dit mais c'est dans trois
ans et on l'aurait fait il y a 3 ans on
les aurait aujourd'hui du coup vous
comprenez le mouvement de grève des
médecins libéraux qui disent il faut il
faut que les axes soient mieux rémunérés
pour qu'on puisse embaucher ces fameuses
assistants médicaux qui qui manquent ce
qu'on est très loin de l'objectif là la
matière oui alors bien bien entendu je
vous ai parlé de l'hôpital mais vous
avez évidemment raison de parler de la
médecine de ville parce que quand la
médecine de ville ne fonctionne pas
c'est l'hôpital qui récupère le truc
parce que les gens sont malades oui bien
sûr
vous savez que dans la vie d'un médecin
libéral en France on considère qu'il y a
par semaine 4 à 6 heures de travail
purement administratif c'est-à-dire tous
les assistants médicaux nous les
assistants médicaux les médecins
libéraux comme les médecins hospitaliers
passent du temps à faire autre chose que
de la médecine et dans tout le monde
comprend que à partir du moment on
devrait avoir ça de médecin on a ça et
bien au moins ce sac qui fasse de la
médecine aura une partie doit faire des
tâches administratives on est chez les
dingues on est chez les dingues mais
puisque vous êtes député je suis libre
juin sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui prévoit des enveloppes pour
l'hôpital hier les députés de la nuque
ont déposé un recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel compte ce budget
dénonçant ses conditions d'examen avec
le 49-3 ils disent que 84% des dépenses
prévues n'ont pas été examinées par la
représentation nationale ils ont raison
si les députés de la nuque disent qu'on
n'a pas eu de débat c'est certain on n'a
pas eu de débat il y a eu une 49-3 on a
eu 49
oui d'abord c'est le jeu démocratique
les députés de la nuque ils sont dans
leur rôle moi j'en vois pas de
difficultés juste sur le le projet de
loi de la sécurité sociale il y a un
élément qui doit alerter le budget a été
construit avec l'hypothèse que
l'épidémie de covid était quasiment
terminée c'est à dire qu'on est passé je
crois de 10 11 milliards d'euros pour
financer des tests l'année dernière à un
milliard cette année ce qui est très
très peu bah oui et deuxièmement il y a
aucune enveloppe vous m'entendez aucune
enveloppe pour la prise en charge du
covid long les fameux séquelles dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure ni sur la
recherche ni sur des consultations
autrement dit demain vous venez me voir
en consultation vous allez voir votre
médecin en consultation parce que vous
souffrez de séquelles du covid moi je ne
sais pas où vous envoyez consulter je
n'ai pas de consultation de covidon donc
non on a un budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui n'est pas adapté à aux
épidémies actuelles on va parler
d'actualité de votre partie puisque on
est en pleine élection à la présidence
secondaire qui opposera Eric ce thyA
Bruno Retailleau qui soutenait vous
depuis le début j'ai soutenu et je
soutiens évidemment encore aujourd'hui
Bruno Retailleau qui est le patron des
sédataires
républicains pourquoi lui
c'est une bonne question je pense qui
est Bruno et quelqu'un qui depuis des
années
à développer une pensée et une réflexion
très structurée or si la droite veut
avoir un espoir de continuer enfin à
réexister on va dire nous n'avons pas
disparu mais au plan national en tout
cas ça passera par les idées oui vous
savez les gens vous disent toujours oui
mais le jour on aura un chef c'est fait
et ils prennent toujours l'exemple de
Sarkozy il y a 15 ans mais ils oublient
un tout petit détail c'est que quand
Nicolas Sarkozy est candidat et gagne
l'élection présidentielle il y a 15 ans
déjà c'est le moyen-âge c'est hier enfin
c'était avant-hier il n'arrive pas comme
ça Nicolas Sarkozy a beaucoup travaillé
sur le fond il y a des idées qui ont été
mis sur la table qui ont été challengés
il y a eu bref
un enrichissement intellectuel de la
droite et donc la conclusion xantir
c'est que si nous voulons de nouveau
exister ça passera d'abord par une un
travail intellectuel extrêmement
important qui sommes-nous pourquoi
sommes-nous droite voyez tous ces
éléments-là sont fondamentaux que pense
nous de tel ou tel sujet avant de
désigner un capitaine et si Éric Ciotti
devait l'emporter vous resteriez fidèle
et oui oui il y a pas de risque de de
scission de la famille
on est à 4,5% à la présidentielle a reçu
si on commence à dire si c'est machin
qui gagne on s'en va je vous propose
d'acheter on achètera une cabine
téléphonique et comme ça au moins les
réunions seront moins coûteuses non que
la frange centriste quitte le parti bah
moi je fais partie de France je suis
quelqu'un je dis souvent c'est plus
facile c'est plus difficile d'être
modéré cradical donc je je m'estime
branche centriste
non enfin d'abord moi je connais bien
Éric Ciotti c'est un même bon camarade
député c'est un homme très sérieux je
sais qu'un certain nombre de des
adversaires prétendent cela je pense que
c'est faux et que
[Musique]
celui qui est élu quel qu'il soit s'il
commence à dire attention à partir du
moment à ce moment-là c'est ma ligne et
je veux plus les autres je veux dire
enfin 4,5 / 2 ça reste on sera plus
nombreux donc santé toujours à l'aise au
public le futur patron des républicains
et c'est c'est je fais pas d'art
divinatoire mais sera forcément
rassembleur parce que sinon la droite
disparaît il y a quand même un risque de
disparition vous êtes inquiet sur une
disparition de votre sortie et de la
droite
je n'ai jamais quitté la républicain
voilà
je suis pas inquiet par nature en
revanche je me dis que encore une fois
les choses ne se font plus naturellement
nous étions naturellement à partir de
gouvernement et bien désormais ce n'est
plus naturel il faut le prouver et il
faut continuer à le prouver par notre
implantation locale que nous avons qu'il
faut cultiver mais qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas fait définitif
beaucoup de mères quittent les
républicains pour aller chez Horizon
alors je suis pas sûr qu'ils aillent
chez Horizon je pense qu'elles vont
nulle part et donc ça nous avons un
enjeu c'est de les retenir en disant
regardez c'est là que intellectuellement
ça se passe et c'est là que nous allons
projeter ce que sera non pas la droite
mais le la France bientôt il y a une
couverture qui m'a beaucoup hérité c'est
la couverture du Figaro on peut citer le
nom il y a trois semaines où on voyait 5
ou 6 visages tous des hommes
accessoirement
quel est l'avenir de la droite mais bon
sang arrêtons de dire l'avenir d'abord
ce sont des hommes ça peut être des
femmes l'avenir ce sont des visages
l'avenir ce sont des idées et la
question c'est pas la droite la question
c'est la France ça va être sur les
alliances parce que c'est une question
Bruno Retailleau dans une interview
Parisien ce matin dit que son premier
acte il devient président sera
d'organiser un référendum interne sur la
question de l'alliance avec Emmanuel
Macron quel sera votre position j'ai
toujours dit que
nous devions essayer d'imposer à la
majorité
une cohabitation tous les mots compte
dans ce que je viens de dire
c'est-à-dire imposer c'est-à-dire dire
voilà nous arrivons avec 5 ou 6 sujets
que nous voulons absolument défendre
souveraineté
énergétique
rénover les services publics moi je
crois à la droite des services publics
bref deux trois sujets fondamentaux les
questions d'immigration évidemment de
contrôle arrêt de l'immigration
immédiate et et et
enfin les questions de sécurité et
arrivé sur la table on va dire voilà
nous nous voulons ces cinq six points et
nous les voulons et à partir de là les
défendre éventuellement dans n'ont pas
une coalition mais une cohabitation
c'est à dire une cohabisation à l'envers
je suis très conscient que ma ligne est
très minoritaire et ce n'est je suis pas
en train de vous dire c'est la ligne du
parti elle est très minoritaire je me
demande si ce n'est pas ça la ligne qui
nous permet de retrouver de la
légitimité et ce serait possible mais à
condition de négocier quelque chose pied
à pied avec avec le gouvernement il
faudrait aussi que partie l'accepte
absolument absolument et ce que dit
Retailleau est assez intéressant
finalement il met sur la table
je ne sais pas en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que c'est la première fois
qu'un quelqu'un qui a des
responsabilités émis dans le parti je
pense à Bruno pose sur la table l'idée
que au moins il faut qu'il se débat
parce que ce n'est pas eu lieu il n'y a
pas eu il faut pas de pacte de
gouvernement selon vous une cohabitation
appeler ça quand vous voulez si elle se
fait au terme que vous souhaitez vous
c'est ça bah oui on arrive avec nos
conditions bien entendu mais qui serait
laquelle vous pensez réussir à imposer
des choses vous êtes en position pour
réussir à imposer des choses à la
majorité présidentielle donc la majorité
on le voit à l'Assemblée c'est son
problème n'arrive ne parviendra
probablement pas à faire passer de texte
facilement pendant 5 ans or le 49.3 bien
sûr et cette cohabitation ça veut dire
sur tout le quinquennat il y a un
certain nombre de texte sur lesquels
vous mettez d'accord sur durant toute la
durée du quinquennat jusqu'à ce que les
accords soient tous remplis encore une
fois la sécurité l'immigration l'énergie
les services publics ce sont des valeurs
de droite merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin la Une de Ouest-France c'est
une question la fin de l'âge d'or pour
les gens du numérique c'est à la Une de
votre journal Stéphane merci Philippe
juin on passe au club des territoires